today very exciting we're going to read
and review
some more woke children's literature we
know that there are many books out there
seeking to
brainwash our kids if you go into a
children's section at barnes noble
right now it it feels like you're being
handed pamphlets at an
antifa rally or something it's nothing
but left-wing extremism everywhere
and that is certainly the case for this
book which is it feels good
to be yourself written by teresa thorne
illustrated by noah
gragini and we're just going to read it
we're going to we're going to find out
what kind of brainwashing is going on
in this book i feel like it's going to
be pretty intense all right
it begins this is ruthie
now you notice from the very beginning
the politically correct assortment of
people
all over this page so they've got
they've got all the different races and
ethnicities
not a lot of white kids i mean the one
white kid there's got the white girl
there but she has blue hair
you're allowed to be white but you have
to dye your hair you have to compensate
by dyeing your hair pink or blue then
we've got
the child walking down playing an
acoustic guitar why not
there's even um an equitable and diverse
assortment
of modes of transportation so there's
the bus the car
and for some reason a unicycle because
when do you and we all see that right
you're driving down the road a
residential neighborhood
and there's just a girl and a unicycle
uh in the in
in the in the the bike lane she's a
transgender girl
that means when she was born everyone
thought she was a boy until she grew a
little older
old enough to tell everyone that she's
actually a girl
everyone was right everyone was right
right the first time
why this is left out why did they think
i mean these these these backwards
neanderthals as joe biden will call them
why did they think that uh quote she was
a boy
well because they made observations
about her
biological nature they made scientific
observations
and that's how they came to the correct
conclusion that he is actually a boy
they leave that out of the book girl is
ruthie's gender identity
and we have to remember gender identity
is a fake
concept and i always have to remind you
if you didn't know this i think it's
really important for people to
understand
where these ideas came from every time
you hear gender identity remember
fake concept invented not just in an
invented concept or
a concept invented generally by the left
it's a concept
pushed by the left but it was invented
originally
by a guy named john money and he was the
pedophilic
um insane lunatic back in the mid 20th
century
who ran sexual experiments on children
including two uh brothers twin twin boys
forcibly performing essentially a
forcible sex change on one of them
and later both boys would go on to kill
themselves that's where it comes from
nothing but misery and despair
and horror this is ruthie's brother
xavier
xavier is a cisgender boy that means
when xavier was born
everyone thought he was a boy and as he
grew older turned out everyone was right
he is a boy boy is xavier's gender
identity
no boy is his biological sex
gender identity not a thing biological
sex is a thing
that's what it is there are so many
different ways to be a boy or a girl
too many to fit in a book but not
everyone feels like either a boy or a
girl
non-binary is a helpful word that can
describe a kid who doesn't feel exactly
like a boy or a girl
so you notice again the pc utopia on
this page
you've got a bearded woman walking a dog
with her lesbian lover then you've got a
cross-dressing boy
playing the trumpet why not and then
we've of course we've got the two the
two gay men uh pushing
a stroller one wearing a t-shirt that
says number one dad so if you're not
getting the message yet
if it's not being if you're not being
hit over the head with the message
enough yet this hopefully will get
the point across um but the real irony
here is they say
there are so many different ways to be a
boy or a girl right two too many ways to
fit in a book
well that's that's correct but
they are making it so that there are not
so many ways
to be our boy or a girl they are the one
gender identity
left-wing gender theory this is the
rigid constricting thing
that confines boys and girls because it
used to be
that you could be a girl and still
wear short hair if you want and play
rough and tumble sports
and play with play in the mud with toy
trucks
and we will call you a tomboy and we
would say that's a valid way to be a
girl that's fine if you want to be a
girl that way you could be a girl that
way
but now we've taken that away from girls
and we've said well if you act like that
you're probably a boy
so in the name of opening everything up
and being open-minded we've actually
constricted it
and made it so that there's one
particular way to be a boy or a girl and
if you go outside of that
then you become the other gender or
other sex
rather alex is both a boy and a girl
no he's not when alex was born
everyone thought alex was a girl but
alex is both a boy and a girl
this is alex's gender identity no this
is insane nonsense
is what this is this is alex's friend jj
jj is neither a boy nor a girl ever
since jj was very little
they never felt exactly like a boy or a
girl they just felt like
themself what does that mean exactly
that he never felt like a boy or a girl
how does he know what a boy or girl
feels like
what are you comparing it to how do you
know that your feelings
are not what a boy feels like how do you
know that
because you've never been the other
things you've nothing to compare it to
this is just one of the logical problems
that i i'm thinking will probably not be
addressed in this book but i could be
wrong
alex and jj are both non-binary just
like there are many different ways to be
a boy and a girl there are many
different ways to be non-binary
too many to fit in a book and even with
all these possible ways to be
some kids don't feel any of the words
they know fit them exactly right
there are a never-ending number of ways
to be yourself in the world
these are ways to be confused what we're
talking about here
are not ways for kids to be themselves
but the opposite of that
these are ways for kids to be confused
about themselves this is not an identity
non-binary is not an identity it's an
anti-identity
it is it is a person refusing to accept
who they are
it's a rejection of identity it's not
the acceptance
it's the rejection of identity this is
someone who either is refusing to accept
who they are
or or if it's a child who's been
brainwashed into this this is a child
who's
never been made to understand who he is
this is the deprivation of identity
whether you feel like a boy a girl both
or neither or if you describe yourself
another way
that is your gender identity your gender
identity might match what people thought
you were when you were born
or it might not see when you were born
you couldn't tell people
who you were or how you felt they looked
at you and made a guess
maybe they got it right maybe they got
it wrong what a baby's body looks like
when they're born can be a clue to what
the baby's gender will be but not always
no see it's not that as a baby you
couldn't tell people who you were
it's that you you didn't know who you
were because you were a baby
and as a baby you don't know anything
babies don't understand anything about
the world
least of all do they understand what a
boy or a girl is so what i can say
from my experience looking down at a
cute little three-month-old baby
if you're wondering what is their how do
they feel about their gender
what are they thinking about their own
gender they're not thinking about it at
all
what they're thinking about is they want
to get fed uh they have to poop they
want to take a nap those are all the
things they're thinking about
and really nothing else they have no
concept of their own quote gender
because they're babies this is something
that children
they have to be educated about this
and that's why when you get to a
four-year-old who says i'm not a boy i'm
actually a girl
but one of the ways that we know that
that's not true aside from the fact that
it simply doesn't make sense
is it they don't know what they're
talking about that boy doesn't know what
a girl is
and that seems like a pretty significant
problem
when someone someone is making a
declaration about who they are and
and they don't know when people guess
wrong it's okay to let them know
ruthie was five when she told her
parents and a little speech bubble says
i know you think i'm a boy but really i
feel like a girl
oops ruthie was a girl all along they
just didn't know it at first
and so the family quickly accepts it
this is what the left wants you to do
your five year old how old is this kid
five year your five-year-old comes up to
you and says
hey um i know you think i'm a boy but
actually turns out i'm a girl
and they want you to say on the spot
well okay then you're a girl
no questions asked we're not going to
even ask the follow-up question
of what do you mean by that
child you say that you're a girl what do
you mean
that seems like a pretty important
follow-up doesn't it
anytime your child is saying anything to
you you should try to understand what
they mean
and it's not always clear what they mean
because they don't have the words to
express they understand very little
about the world
they understand very little about about
themselves and what they want what's
best for them
and so they don't have the words to
express that's why kids do a lot of
screaming and crying and they throw
temper tantrums because they can't
express what they actually want
and that's why it's really important
even when your kid
is clear and says i want this it's
important for you as the adult in the
situation
to understand why they're actually
saying that
that to me seems like an important
follow-up i'm a girl
what do you mean what do you mean you're
a girl ask that question and what you're
gonna find out is what the boy is
actually saying
is that he wants to wear a pink shirt
because he thinks pink is a pretty color
fine wear the pink shirt you're still
not a girl though when people guess
right it's also okay to let them know
xavier was three and a half when he told
his family i'm a boy i like being a boy
yeah so i'll never forget the day that
my child announced to me that he
is himself dad turns out i'm myself
good i was i wasn't sure your feelings
about your gender are real
listen to your heart no matter what your
gender identity is you're okay exactly
the way you are
and you are loved it feels good to be
yourself
doesn't it yeah your feelings about your
gender
are real but that doesn't mean
that they reflect reality okay that's
the distinction
that so many people struggle with your
feelings are real
you really do feel this way
but that doesn't mean that it is an
accurate reflection of what
is that's the point
and that is what is not covered in this
book and what i wouldn't expect to be
covered
because all you get here is
indoctrination and brainwashing and
that's why this book and so many books
like it are poison
what i would say is i'm not into banning
books i'm not into burning books
but if we're going to ban and cancel
books how about a book like this
and not dr seuss